President Biden says he will move on gun
control during the lame duck session of
Congress before the Republican Party
takes control of the house next year the
president said he will try to pass a
bill Banning assault rifles by the end
of this year he's also dealing with
potential major economic setbacks that
could be felt during the holiday
shopping season that includes a workers
strike at Amazon the world's largest
online retailer and a nationwide
Railroad Strike that could begin early
next month Nancy Cordis is in Nantucket
Massachusetts where the president is
spending the holiday weekend Nancy good
morning
good morning Dana yeah the president is
taking a break here in Breezy Nantucket
with his family ahead of a legislative
Sprint for his party at the end of the
year before Republicans take control of
the house come January
[Music]
many Americans the bidens did some Black
Friday shopping showing support for
retail workers in person and online as
Amazon workers went on strike or
protested in 30 countries
[Applause]
supporting working people is how we
continue to build the economy President
Biden tweeted vowing to achieve a 15
minimum wage the biggest concern for
Shoppers this holiday season is
inflation which eased slightly last
month but remains near record highs
instead of buying multiple gifts I'm
just limited to one gift per person some
folks aren't even getting gifts seems
like every time you go out of the house
you spend 100 bucks
[Music]
Nantucket may be a winter wonderland but
real world problems keep intruding
looming possible Railroad Strike after
unions rejected a supposed deal with
rail companies my team has been touching
all parties President Biden also weighed
in on the latest mass shooting this one
at a Walmart in Chesapeake Virginia that
left six people dead the idea we still
allow semi-automatic weapons to be
purchased is sick just sick it has no no
social media value zero none
Mr Biden told reporters here that he's
determined to pass an assault weapons
ban but he doesn't have the votes and
the chances get even Slimmer once
Republicans take control of the house
President Biden is going to remain here
in Nantucket over the weekend before
heading back to Washington D.C and White
House aides say one of the things he's
going to be doing here over the weekend
is talking with extended family about
his decision about whether he's going to
seek re-election in 2024. Errol
all right Nancy thank you from a
picturesque Nantucket we appreciate it